why the charade to give people hope
detective oh so I could rip it away from
you just don't care no I don't his about
maintenance hunters all as a convicted
serial killer
and faster than I've ever been
I can take them down
hey youtubers it's Charlie this is gonna
be my flash episode 18 trailer video all
about zooms backstory who is confirmed
hunter zolomon
I'm getting a real true crime vibe from
the flash this season now this trailer
makes it seem like they did making a
murderer their version of making a
murderer cross with Clockwork Orange
some Hannibal Lecter in there so this is
gonna be a lot of fun why keep up the
charade so that I can give people hope
and take it away from them you know the
trailer doesn't completely spell
everything out now we know this little
kid here is hunter zolomon but the actor
Teddy Sears is also playing this
character here that looks like Jay
Garrick so maybe hunter zolomon is Jay
Garrick son that remains to be seen
there's no explanation for that right
now but remember there are a couple
versions a couple physical versions of
Jay Garrick you have hunter zolomon who
looks just like Jay Garrick who is the
zoom character the big villain of the
season then you have this dead Jay
Garrick that he killed and yanked back
through the wormhole then you have the
man in the iron mask which might be
another version of Jay Garrick it might
be this older version here because this
looks like a flashback just explaining
how soon went from being this innocent
little kid to being this murderer right
now that's why I say this trailer makes
it seem like the flash season two is all
about zoom making a murderer if you ever
saw the Netflix series now if you
haven't seen that Netflix series it's
all about the failure of the American
justice system this man is innocent he
gets framed for a sexual assault serves
18 years in prison within two years of
his release after that 18 year period he
is sent back to prison for a murder so
the whole idea of the Netflix series
making a murderer is the idea that the
American justice system failed the first
time it sent an innocent man to prison
then the prison system failed him turned
him into the murderer today so look at
this flash trailer you have this
innocent little kid maybe something bad
happens to him when he gets thrown into
foster care he gets arrested for a crime
as a young adult thrown into the earth
to prison system and gets subjected to
crazy Hannibal Lecter treatment and
turned into an actual murderer so that's
what I mean when I say the flash might
be doing his version of making a
murderer the earth-2
justice system failed the child hunter
zolomon turned him into an actual
murderer and then he got his speed force
powers and became zoom now they haven't
really explained velocity-9 how he's
getting faster so what I'm guessing
we're gonna see is him maybe get framed
for something slowly twisted by the
treatment he receives while he's growing
up or wise in prison you know somehow
the world of earth-2 fails him but he
becomes a scientist gets speed force
powers and then slowly develops the
velocity-6 formula they haven't really
explained whether or not he's actually a
scientist on earth - or if that's a lie
we'll just have to wait for the episode
to learn about the timeline because he
might grow up to be a scientist but then
along the way is psychologically twisted
by the treatment that he receives maybe
he's abused as a child it just feels
like that's what the flash is going to
do it's all about Redemption the flash
is all about Redemption
they've even kind of redeemed the
reverse-flash character during last
week's flashback episode you Bart Thawne
even though he's you know inside the
body of Harrison wells is able to help
bury knowing that he's gonna get
something out of it in the future I feel
like what they're gonna do in the next
couple of episodes of the flash is
explain why zoom is so crazy and why
he's hell-bent on killing as many people
as he can and then answering the
question if it's possible for someone to
come back from that
like when Barry was talking to Supergirl
during the Supergirl crossover episode
where she got dosed with red kryptonite
and she went apeshit on a bunch of
people she's like how do I get the
public to trust me again
Barry's like that happened to me last
season I went crazy don't worry
give them time Barry wasn't that bad
when he got dosed by rainbow Raider in
season one during the flash versus arrow
crossover so it wasn't that hard for him
to come back from he didn't murder
anyone like zoom has so what I'm really
hoping is is that they do try to answer
that question like hey maybe there's a
good person inside there that's just
been twisted somehow maybe we can redeem
him but then ultimately saying that you
know some people are just too far gone
to come back I really want them to find
a way for Jay Garrick to exist on the
show as a good character like the Jay
Garrick that you know from the comics
and also let the hunter zolomon zoom
character continue to exist in some form
or another the key to that right now
seeing how both of those characters
could possibly exist in present day is
all going to depend on how they explain
the difference between this Jay Garrick
body here and
hunter zolomon like is he a clone is the
twin how they can explain it so let me
know in the comments look at this
picture
who is this version of Jay Garrick and
how is he related to hunter zolomon is
the hunter zolomon father or is he clone
or is he something else not to forget
about the influence of velocity-9 that's
where the blue lightning comes in so
what I'm guessing is is that you have an
unbalanced individual who then on top of
that takes velocity-9
and that turns him crazy evil so zoom
abuse by the justice system Hannibal
Lecter style here gets speed force
powers so he's already unbalanced then
experiments with velocity 9 or velocity
6 however you want to think about it and
turns crazy evil still does not explain
though where all these other versions of
Jay Garrick are coming from because this
body here is definitely another version
of him whether it's a twin or a clone
remains to be seen I just I can't wait
to see how they explain it I really like
the direction they're going with this I
was actually kind of worried for a
little while but when I saw this making
a murderer flash trailer I just got so
excited if you are worried that the
flash is gonna totally try and redeem
zoom don't worry I think they're just
gonna ask the question I think that he
will continue to be a villain but
they'll also find a way for the good Jay
Garrick to exist in this universe so why
you guys wait for my next video to post
you can click here for this week's
episode of the flash and you can click
here for my Suicide Squad trailer that I
just posted thank you so much watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you
guys tonight
you